STATES ARE FACING.
JILLIAN: I THINK WE SHOULD HEAR
FROM HIM RIGHT NOW, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US.
LET’S BRING IN A MEMBER OF
PROTECT ADVISORY COMMITTEE,
WAYNE IV.
GOOD TO SEE YOU HERE.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> THE DIFFERENT FLORIDA
AGENCIES SENDING AID TO THE
BORDER SPECIFICALLY ARIZONA AND
TEXAS.
TELL ME WHY YOU DECIDED TO DO
THAT.
>> IT IS OUTRAGEOUS DEPUTIES AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT GO TO THE BORDER
BEFORE THE VICE PRESIDENT.
WE WORKED TOGETHER IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT, RHONDA SANTOS,
MAKING SURE WE’RE STANDING
BEHIND TEXAS AND ARIZONA, TO
FIGHT THIS CRISIS.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS THAT IT IS
TAKING PLACE AND TAKING PLACE
BECAUSE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
OPENED THE FLOODGATES, ALLOWED
EVERYONE TO COME IN WITH NO
CONTROL AND NOTHING ELSE AND
TRYING TO PUT THE PIECES
TOGETHER.
>> SENDING HELP THE DIFFERENT
STATES, DO YOU HAVE ENOUGH
RESOURCES ON HANDING YOUR
COMMUNITY TO DO THE JOB YOU NEED
TO DO FOR THOSE WHO LIVE THERE?
>> THAT IS THE POINT.
NONE OF US KNOW WHAT THAT WILL
LOOK LIKE.
THE GOVERNOR IS WORKING WITH
TEXAS AND ARIZONA TO IDENTIFY
WHAT RESOURCES HE CAN PULL FROM
AND WHAT IT WILL LOOK LIKE IS 5
OR 6 DAYS AWAY.
IT WILL BE A JOINT PERFORMANCE
BETWEEN STATE REINFORCES AND
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT BUT THE
WAY TO LOOK AT THIS IS WE CAN
FIGHT THIS BATTLE OUT THERE AT
THE BORDER OR FIGHT IT IN OUR
OWN BACKYARD.
THE INCREASE OF ILLEGALS
CROSSING THE BORDER, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE INCREASE OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND THE INCREASE IN
FENTANYL AND MYTH AND THE IMPACT
OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION THAT
FILTER INTO COMMUNITIES WE WILL
FIGHT THIS BATTLE SO WE ARE
FIGHTING TOGETHER AT THIS.
>> I HEAR WHAT YOU ARE SAYING.
THERE ARE A LOT OF DIFFERENT
BATTLES LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
ARE FIGHTING, THIS BEING ONE OF
THEM WAS ANOTHER ONE BEING THE
RISE IN CRIME.
ARE YOU SEEING A RISE IN CRIME?
WHAT ARE THE BATTLES YOU ARE
FIGHTING IN YOUR COMMUNITY RIGHT
NOW?
>> IN BREVARD COUNTY, FLORIDA,
WE ARE BLESSED, THEY TRUST AND
PROTECT US.
IT IS AN AMAZING FEELING TO
SERVE AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IN BREVARD COUNTY.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF THE
STATE OF FLORIDA, NO ONE HERE IS
BUYING INTO THE INSANITY, WE
HAVE A GOVERNOR SHOWING WHAT
LEADERSHIP LOOKS LIKE IN FLORIDA
SO WE ARE PRETTY BLESSED, WE ARE
FIGHTING THE SAME BATTLE SOME
OTHER AREAS ARE WITH FENTANYL
DEATH AND OVERDOSE, CERTAINLY TO
MAKE SURE WE ARE ABLE TO PROTECT
OUR CITIZENS.
SHERIFFS FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY
JOINED TOGETHER TO PROTECT
AMERICA NOW AND WE ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO FIGHT THE CRISIS AT
THE BORDER, THE DEFUND THE
POLICE AND IT IS A JOINT EFFORT
OF EVERYBODY WORKING TOGETHER
FOR THE SAME CAUSE OF PROTECTING
CITIZENS AND THAT IS THE BIGGEST
FACTOR EVERYBODY NEEDS TO LOOK
AT.
WE HAVE TO POOL OUR RESOURCES
TOGETHER.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WON’T DO
THEIR JOB WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT PULLING TOGETHER.
>> WE ARE OF TIME, 10 SECONDS,
YOU FEEL PROTECTED IT SUPPORTED
BY YOUR COMMUNITY, DO YOU BE
SUPPORTED BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION?
>> ABSOLUTELY NOT.
A COMPLETE TURNAROUND FROM WHAT
WE HAD PRIOR TO THIS
ADMINISTRATION, 0 SUPPORT FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT, LAW ENFORCEMENT